six officers involved in the January
abuse case of two black men in Rankin
County appeared in court today for to
face State charges 12 News Tia McKenzie
she is live from the ranky county court
with more on today's hearing child the
courtroom was packed to maximum capacity
as those six officers pleaded guilty
once again this time to State charges
Britt mcalpin Jeffrey Middleton
Christian Dead Man Hunter L word Daniel
Opdyke and Joshua Hartfield each entered
the Rankin County Courthouse risk
Shackled to their waist in jail suits
prosecutors today described the heinous
X that occurred during the raid on a
Braxton home the officers received word
that that black men were saying with a
white woman there the officers spoke
with each other in cold phrases such as
work easy and no bag mug shots before
raiding the home beating and torturing
Michael Jenkins and Eddie Parker Jenkins
was shot in the mouth during the
encounter the six officers pleaded
guilty to several federal charges
earlier this month
of the pleaded guilties because the case
against them was so sure it was so crazy
it was so clear-cut that if they pleaded
none guilty they wouldn't get they
wouldn't get even more the cops almost
never plead guilt to these kinds of
cases but in this case not only were
these guys 100 guilty but the people
prosecuted and already had all the
evidence
covered in chocolate syrup and other
liquids shortly after MJ and EP were
ordered to strip naked and shower off
their handcuffs were removed after MJ
and EP showered off and changed into
clean underwear and sweats they were
hand pumped again and brought to the
side of that room adjacent to the
carport the officers began discussing
the prepared strength of their
respective tasers and they decided to
test their tasers on NJ and EP to see
which one was the most powerful
what did a person do to deserve this
sleep with the caucus Queens
carry on what well no no no we're not
carrying on that's all he did just
because he was sleeping with a girl
obviously the white woman who was
involved in this case is probably
related to one of the officers oh and if
I remember correctly this is like in
Mississippi or some [__]
yeah you disagree with what she said
okay so they admit to everything that
she said in regards to tasering the
dudes into it as I understand it for
some of the details it even involved
some uh bedroom toys being inserted in
some of the men uh Firearms being
inserted in their mouths and one of the
Firearms ended up going off while inside
the mouth of the person thus blowing off
a portion of their face the person did
survive
both extra holes in them
and activity you're turning you want to
decide till they get there okay at this
point he's just basically reading out
the plea letting him know like are you
you know what year it is that you're
pleading guilty to and these guys
accepting everything the lawyers have
already had this hash this out Rankin
County Sheriff Brian Bailey released a
statement in in part I believe today is
guilty please show the community that
our system of checks and balances is
effective as for those six officers they
are expected to be sentenced in
mid-november live in Rankin County Tia
McKenzie 12 news thank you so much Tia
Will rankey County Sheriff Brian Bailey
also included in his statement on
today's Court proceedings that quote The
Rankin County Sheriff's Office continues
to evaluate and modify its policies
procedures and training for all
Sheriff's Office employees so many
initial thoughts
I just need to
return
it's a lot
they did all those ah man was it
sentencing
well they're State charges let's see
here
and there's some federal charges
so I gotta admit this is probably going
to be
a minimum of 12 years that's it so I'll
just read out some of the stuff the
former officers pleaded guilty August
3rd to federal charges the case in which
the U.S prosecutor said the former
officers kicked down the door of a home
in Braxton Mississippi where the black
men were living and then
basically began Consulting them for two
hours
both physically and the sexual nature
yeah the officers did not have a warrant
and some called themselves the Goon
Squad they don't have a warrant for what
that booty hole I don't think a warrant
and you're think that even with a
warrant actually you can go inside
Buddhist War I understand
stuff like that Jesus Christ I don't
think that's the kind of Warrant we're
looking for all right hey officer I want
some booty
now I'm gonna have some booty now we
could either do this the legal way or we
can do this in the hallway but I might
have some booty I'm sorry I don't know
why I do nothing because I I was
thinking about the same thing with you
all right so they call themselves The
Goon Squad because of their willingness
to use excessive force and not report it
according to a federal charging document
okay so they had a reputation in this
department the six officers were charged
with the combined 13 felonies in
connection with the torturing the
physical abuse of the two men that night
the lawyer for when the guy says he
takes full responsibility for his part
on the horrific harms portrayed by Mr
Jenkins and Mr Parker
the victims and is prepared to face the
consequences of his misconduct the
deputies in the repeated use of racial
slurs in the course of their violent
Acts were oppressive and hateful against
their African-American victims so the
word used slurs used against this and
there wasn't part a huge racial
component to how all this started
defendants were motivated on the basis
of race and the color of the skin of the
persons they went after
okay here we go according to Federal
charging documents Deadman texted L word
Middleton and odd Pike Leisure officers
on January 24th about going to the
property in Braxton to resolve a
complaint received by mcalpin okay
mcalpin's white neighbor
told him several black men were staying
at a white woman's home and repeated
reported seeing suspicious Behavior oh
it has nothing to do with one of them
[__] in the officer's wife I thought
that's what you meant it's not even that
I I might be honest with you somebody's
[__] that woman
yeah somebody's [__] that woman but
that was not no officer's wife that was
the neighbor yeah someone's girl
that girl and that officer involved
is that written
no that I'm not going to say that I will
why because it's not just a white woman
and a black man that's not that is that
that woman is involved with one of the
dudes do you understand there's no
relation they just saw a random black
man arriving oh they had a complaint
from the neighbor that's what you just
read by the neighbor yes but if the
neighbor knows the officer Uber's like
the neighbor's like yeah
someone [__] yo oh one of the women
in the
they know they all know each other this
is that's how it is they all know each
other okay Deadman warned the deputies
there might be surveillance cameras on
the property telling them to knock on
the door instead of knocking it down if
they saw any the documents stated
otherwise they could barge in without a
warrant the document could see it no bad
mug shots he said meaning prosecutor
said the defendants could use excessive
force on parts of their body that would
not be seen in a mug shot yeah
avoiding a surveillance camera above the
front door dead men odd Pike and L word
broke open the carpet door while
Hartfield kicked open the back door the
document stated they encountered Parker
who was living there to help take care
of the women who owned the property and
his friend Jenkins who was staying there
temporarily over the next two hours the
two men were subjugated to grueling
violence at the hands of these officers
they're reportedly tased called racial
slurs the officers poured milk alcohol
and chocolate syrup in their mouths
Edward threw eggs at the men and dead
men poured grease on Parker's hands
eventually Edward moved a bullet from
his gun
Forge Jenkins onto his knees and put the
gun in his mouth
Edward fired the gun which did not
discharge then racked the slide put the
gun back in Jenkins mouth and pull the
trigger again
okay that was that was intentional then
right outside put the gun back in
Jenkins mouth pulled the gun back uh
pulled the trigger again according to
documents a bullet lacerated Jenkins
tongue broke his jaw and went out
through his neck
according to the charging documents
officer then devised a cover story
discussing a planting gun Middleton had
in his patrol car on Jenkins
that means that they already have guns
waiting to be planted on people so that
they can make sure the story gets out
now here's what's really twisted this is
a detail that I think is probably the
most key in this whole thing
this went on for months without nobody
even noticing until one of the officers
came forward and then snitched on the
other guys meaning
they would have gotten away with it it's
contrary if it wasn't for those stupid
meddling kits
I feel like this from a cartoon
somewhere but if it wasn't for that one
officer who snitched so when people like
what these kinds of things happen more
often than you might actually believe
maybe less than some people claim but
definitely more often than many of you
believe you just never came here about
it because the proof is oftentimes not
possible when these guys go through
these processes their burden to proved
to be able to prove that they didn't do
anything wrong it's not that high he
just had to plant the good that they
already had staked away all it required
was for someone to break the line and
say this actually happened for things to
change but you have to consider how many
times do they not do this the fact that
they even have a reputation as a goon
squad being said they've definitely
crossed that line so many times before
and they know about it and people in the
department know about it and you think
about it and they not do nothing
so just that's just something to be
mindful of but instead L word planted a
BB gun the officers discarded one shell
case in the document say that heartfelt
threw the men's soiled clothes in the
woods took the hard drive from the home
surveillance system before throwing it
in a creek according to the document
like they taught like they went through
all that trouble for what you gotta
imagine they gotta have some connection
with either defendants or the person the
woman that has to be one of those two I
refuse to believe they just saw two band
and then they went through all that
trouble and tortured there's something
else that's an element to this and
that's why I don't think they can talk
about it unfortunately but it felt very
personal probably won't be able to
gather more information because uh the
court filings probably stuff to go
through to some degree
that has we'll get it after everybody's
prosecuted properly so we'll see we'll
have to find out but I'm I'm betting on
I'm betting on 13 years after that's
what I think they're probably gonna end
up serving get out with good good
behavior
I'll probably be a sentence like 20 20.
yeah nobody died for attempted murder no
nobody died so it's not like a 25 to
Life thing no attempted
attempted attempted is very good and
then the additional charges and
depending on how the state charges work
yeah it could be concurrent so they
might have to do the time for the
attempted and then everything else as
well consecutive you mean yeah
yeah
um I wouldn't know how these these like
these you'd have to research state law
in Mississippi I'm not yeah I'm not that
good in that yeah what do you think
about the case or anything in the story
what do you want to say it's kind of
weird
there's definitely elements that are
missing okay still nonetheless
um that's a bit crazy
which go back to what I was said in a
couple of times don't be me was messing
with nobody's wives
you said that a couple of times yeah I
don't know I think especially depending
on where you live at don't be messing
with white women
and y'all think it's a meme sometimes
but in some places that's just that's
actually just true now I ain't got much
to say about that
I don't know I can't get over that one
detail that one detail just only sticks
out to me yeah they went about their
jobs like nothing they had these guys
ready to plant on people and they don't
got cocked somebody snitched and had it
conscious and you all need you only I
don't even know if it's that maybe he
sleeps for different reasons I don't
know why he did but he did so at the end
of the day that's the only thing so if
that's the difference between bad
officers getting caught a lot of times
and not getting caught like how does
that make me feel real sure because I
know most of the time they not gonna do
that and it's not even something that's
shocking to me you know like even in the
military like some some people will
cover for others because why you know
the Brotherhood or whatever it is is
stronger oftentimes than the duty now
for some people that's not the case the
duty comes first uh but for a lot of
them it's not and so I think I think
that's the part that doesn't feel very
reassuring they caught six
how many more